y bastante activos sobre todo el
presidente de trump aprovechando estas
últimas horas antes de que cierren las
las urnas
aprovechando trump y bailén también pues
este último momento que tiene trump
estuvo en arlington nuestro mencionado
previamente también esta mañana pues
trompa uno con fox news es un medio de
comunicación preferido dijo que la
ventaja de esta noche sería aún más
grande que la ventaja desde hace cuatro
años cuando le ganó a hillary clinton
por su parte y bailén estuvo en
pensilvania yanes cuanto en su ciudad
natal y pensilvania nuevamente insiste
el candidato demócrata porque sabella ya
hay 20 votos electorales que le podrían
dar la clave para incluso perder uno de
los estados bisagra de los estados
pendulares como la florida o como
arizona y llegar a la cifra mágica de
los 270 votos electorales los dos
candidatos
bailén estará en delaware ya esperar a
los resultados después de su viaje por
pensilvania
presidente de donald trump estará en la
casa blanca en compañía de mike pence de
su vicepresidente allá esperará los
resultados con una fiesta que dicen va a
ser de 250 personas y va a ser más
grande pero por temas de seguridad y la
pandemia se tuvo que reducir a 250
personas le doy algunos datos de
seguridad aquí en black lights mar plaza
hay 250 hombres de la guardia nacional
que están vigilando la zona
esta valla negra ya me estuvo contando
uno de los a de los agentes de seguridad
acá fue una valla que contrató el
servicio secreto también en casi un
millón de dólares para pues en cercar el
área de la casa blanca la policía
metropolitana también ha acercado tres
cuadras a la redonda esta plaza
blacklight mater y pues estos 250
hombres estarán muy pendientes para
evitar cualquier tipo de desmanes acá
desde el centro de la capital
estadounidense